historic day today on Capitol Hill as
public impeachment hearings begin the
first two witnesses facing off
Republican lawmakers the GOP claiming a
testimony relies on hearsay evidence and
president Trump reacting just a short
time ago just after their hearing what
are you talking about the witch-hunt is
that what you mean is that what you're
talking about I hear it's a joke I
haven't watched I haven't watched for
one minute because I've been with the
president which is much more important
as far as I'm concerned this is a sham
and shouldn't be allowed and I want to
find out who is the whistleblower
because the whistleblower gave a lot of
very incorrect information including my
call with the president of Ukraine which
was a perfect call aside from that there
was also a back-and-forth about hunter
Biden today and whether there were
concerns about his possible conflict of
interest watch this I raised my concern
that hunter Biden status as a board
member could create the perception of a
conflict of interests let me be clear
however I did not witness any effort by
any US official to shield burr yzma from
scrutiny ambassador Taylor do you know
whether hunter Biden offers anything
other than the fact that his dad's the
former vice president
I don't were at the time was the vice
president I have no knowledge of hundred
Biden well you would agree to raises
questions right he was getting paid I
think $50,000 a month to sit on the
board that exchange Jesse gets to this
question of the Republicans asking for
hunter Biden to be one of the witnesses
that is called they don't know if it
will be granted but they keep being in
that drum yeah that's never gonna happen
but I do want to zero in on Kent our
vote I friend I thought it was a risk
with the bow tie here we go I think at
the end it worked for him he said some
breaking news can help with the
Republican point of view here he
testified under oath want that buries
m'a was corrupt to the core and he
wanted it investigated he said the owner
of buries m'a stole billions of dollars
from Ukraine all of their energy
licenses paid off a prosecutor and then
fled the country he said that he raised
concerns to the Biden team about hunter
joining Bereza and gotten
thing from that and then he said Kent
the Democrat star witness said that
there was nothing wrong with President
Trump bringing up Purisima in the phone
call with the Ukrainian president that
was totally normal and then he mentioned
the treaty that I mention all the time
on this show that he had total legal
authority to mention that at the end he
said that when asked about Joe Biden do
you think Joe Biden's since he's running
for president should not be investigated
he said no one is above the law
and I think those were all great points
for the Republic let me help you yeah I
don't know I'm glad to help you know
because it's so important that everyone
understand there's nothing wrong with
the president if he's representing the
United States saying it's in the
national security interest of this
country to go after corruption in the
Ukraine but instead what the president's
say Joe Biden Purisima not because he's
interested in corruption he's interested
in Joe Biden you can't just lose the
leverage of US national security it's
not drugs money this is not a business
deal this is the president representing
us and saying I'm going to use American
dollars to get dirt on my didn't say
that it is getting okay do you want to
take this yeah so the the reason why the
corruption element is relevant here with
Purisima is because Purisima is a
corrupt company and hunter biden was
being paid by the company and then
lobbyists surrounding the company and
other companies in ukraine were then
going to the State Department in trying
to leverage hunter Biden's last name to
get special favors so that is why there
is a corruption element when it comes to
the president mentioned mentioning Burr
yzma and having questions about what the
roles were of everybody involved Andy
can you cite me one case one case where
the president this our president has
gone after corruption yeah where it
didn't involve getting dirt on a
political opponent yeah he's gone after
corruption in Central America
chyna want you to know one more note on
that you know Solinsky the president of
Ukraine was elected to try and combat
this corruption he's a new generation
and after the hearing I thought what
Adam Schiff said about him was very
interesting so now they're going after
the character and the credibility of the
Ukrainian president because he keeps
saying Thank You Patton the witnesses
said today that he's not lying when he
says he wasn't pressured by the
president now Adam Schiff is going out
in front of the cameras and saying well
he's new he doesn't necessarily know
what he was doing the people have so
much faith in him that he and do this
but maybe he was pressured by the desert
and could have Gregan because the other
thing that Bill Taylor said about
szalinski was that he was new and that
he was really excited about him because
he was actually going to start doing
some of the things that the United
States had been asking for on he didn't
seem like somebody who was being
extorted or he had no problems with what
was going on the fact is you can't turn
off leverage when you're a boss it's
implied whether you say it or not Danny
when you ask your assistant for a
sandwich you don't say
can I have a sandwich or or else the or
else is implied because you're a monster
you're a monster and if you just need a
sandwich it's over if you'll stop paying
you'll stop a neck turn on Greg guts but
I'm no the fact is its money I like
every but every leverage is there
whether you like it or not the thing
about the one thing I like about this
this element of the impeachment process
this inquiry the media is always trying
to place it into two prisons you know
you either got to be four or it gets but
the Biden thing destroys the whole thing
because they didn't see that coming now
you got to be forth the inquiry even if
it destroys Biden it's true no more
prison to two ideas in New York or do a
story about this